[Music]
when I'm juggling I feel like I have a
superpower to me it's just an amazing
feeling to keep lots of things in the
air and to keep these big patterns going
[Music]
Sam Malcolm is a combat juggler the
object of the sport it's to keep all
three pins in the air while preventing
your opponent from doing likewise light
bumping and onto um altercations are
permitted the last struggler standing
wins I got into combat juggling at about
3 a.m. at a juggling convention playing
around with some friends just trying to
see who could be the last one standing
we've all been to circuses we've all
seen variety acts but this is something
that makes it more of a sport if you're
playing football you have to put in the
work to get good at football juggling is
no different you have to put in hours
and hours and hours of practice you're
not only accounting for the three
objects that you're juggling you have to
anticipate that there could be something
flying at your head from 50 feet in the
air
because it's so held and crazy there's
so many other people playing I warm up
for combat juggling I jump rope for
about 10 minutes I work on balancing
things when my head and on my face
there's a lot of wild throws there's a
lot of wild saves there's a lot of
jumping around and falling and running
on the ground and I try to go through
all of those things to get ready
you see incredible plays by people like
Steph Curry or LeBron James I can look
at those people and tell you like they'd
be great jugglers because I have that
awareness suffers their body it's
something new and exciting and fresh
something fun it's something different
so I'm optimistic that it'll grow and
become something really great
[Music]
people may not think pizza tossing is a
serious sport it really is it's a lot of
hard work
[Music]
my name is Tony Gemignani and I'm a
12-time world pizza champion I have two
Guinness Book of World Records one for
most consecutive rolls across his
shoulders in 30 seconds it was 36 rolls
across the shoulders 36 or 37 yeah we'll
say 37 so Pizza acrobatics are tricks
with pizza dough a lot of people ask me
you know pizza throwing how do you
describe it it's kind of like a what a
Harlem Globetrotter does with a
basketball but we do with the pizza you
know around the back across the
shoulders through the legs two at a time
on the ground spinning in your hands the
difference between you know a basketball
and a pizza it misshapes it gets bigger
and gets softer not like it's juggling
balls that are always the same it's
pretty magical so every year in Las
Vegas there's Pizza Expo and that the
Pizza Expo there's a world Pizza games
when you walked it out with stage
there's acrobats from all around the
world competing they'll be getting
judged by a panel of three to five
judges and those judges will look for
dexterity creativity difficulty and as
they're judging them they'll look for
drops and they'll look for transitions
from trick to trick there's about a two
to three minute routine in music they
have to nail it they've been practicing
all year for it there's a trick in the
sport called the Gemignani my last name
it's a trick that I did it's two across
the shoulders and you catch it
nobody loves pizza more than me no even
I have on my chest it's a pizza for life
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's like a symphony of manipulating and
spinning and flipping the cards in your
hands it's like each move inspires the
next and you're not even thinking about
it
the cards are dancing between the hands
they're spinning around they're flipping
over they're doing things you wouldn't
even expect them to be doing it's just
so surprising almost magical
[Music]
for as long as I can remember we've
always done things in tandem together we
both got into magic around the age of 12
we would go to the library and check out
books by diver Ninh Chi Hollingworth
just seeing the illustrations were like
wow we can do this with playing cards
when we started practicing cardistry it
wasn't a thing it has its roots in magic
it comes from card magicians who would
use what is called the card flourish and
these were used to accentuate certain
moments in a magic trick so we took that
and just ran with it
we were the first to embrace it and
really focus on it and practice it as
its own thing and promote it as its own
thing cardistry is very much like
skateboarding you know we practice these
tricks until we have them down perfect
you know we see other tricks and we're
like oh we gotta learn that you have 52
playing cards and the possibilities to
to maneuver those around are endless you
can hold the deck of cards in your hand
and it's one solid block now imagine
lifting up another block so now you have
two what can you do with those two
blocks in your hands well you can create
more blocks and we call those packets
and you can start maneuvering and
spinning and flipping those packets
between your fingers it's hard like it
takes a lot of dexterity it's all
practiced it's all rehearsed and when
you're truly a master and you can just
start doing things on the fly and you
don't even have to think about it
[Music]
what kids are doing today with cards is
mind-blowing if you would have told me
that when I was 14 years old I would
have been like that's the coolest thing
I had no idea it could even be this big
the ultimate goal would be to get people
to almost put cardistry first when they
see a deck of playing cards you know
it's no longer for games it's no longer
for gambling it's Carter Street
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I perform on stage I'm in my own
world the only thing going through my
head is that nothing else exists what
the trick I'm doing in that current
moment the do yo things up in the air
goes under my leg it's being bounced
back and forth between the strings with
being sideways horizontally the way I
express myself on stage comes out and I
love that feeling where you could kind
of be free when I'm not on stage I'm a
graphic designer
living in Los Angeles most of the year
I'm just like any typical recent grad
trying to figure out what to do with
their life but come summer I'm preparing
to be the best yo-yo performer at the
world yo-yo contest my name is Ben Conde
I am a professional yo-yo player and I'm
ranked number one in North America and
the offstring division I think people
think yo-yos are incredibly simple but
it's gone a long way since being a toy
that goes up and down and now there's
all these new elements to it many people
don't know there are five styles of
yo-yo there's one handed yo-yo there's
two handed responsive yo-yo two handed
unresponsive yo-yo counterweight helio
and off string yo-yo which is what I
specialize in it's riskier it's the
riskiest division in my opinion because
of the fact that it can fall off the
string for the past 19 years I've been
working on yo-yo tricks trying to figure
out what tricks to do that's half the
battle
[Music]
because you're performing those tricks
to music one of the hardest parts is
telling a story through your music
giving the right energy and work on
making something flow it's a lot of hard
work that you put into it in any split
second of losing focus it seems like a
whole years of work goes the weight I
have to prove that I'm not gonna waste
audience's time and for people to
respond positively towards it that I
like can't thank the sport no I started
playing yo-yo when I was four years old
and it's something I care about it's not
something I do for money like it's a toy
it's a toy at simplest form and I just
happened to be competing with it for a
really long time and spending a lot of
time learning in the end it's something
that makes me feel comfortable
it keeps me youthful it reminds me of
what I would be playing with as a kid
[Music]